per tutti con maniero amico benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video di relax league
sono con il buon laurentiis che amber
one giocare la bella lo sapete
facciamo un 2 p2 tattico estremo let's
go dov'è allora lui dovrà vuoi dove vuoi
eccolo reti e grandezza non mi ha
risposto però i bachi e gol
perché hai ragione deve gente perché
devo dire niente quando io lo so è
esclusa ok ok ok io sono tutto il nostro
lato cattivissimo ma quanto ero fa
quando i bambini a proprio che si sono
hanno spento il computer questo era un
colpo dl pd non ha fatto altro parato
marotta 9 ago me ed avevo anche tolto il
mio bene farà lui la casa a segno altri
colpi
l'ho spinto ma tranquilla dopo solar
thermal così facciamo un controllo
tranquillo però magari lo scartiamo la
prossima volta
non ho scoperto la porta quel punto non
ci arriva e dove va bene ti facevi
sembra però comunque e palo traversa era
veramente una poesia va bene che la
butta in mezzo cattivo no non è vero io
prima lui da sono portata talmente forte
e sono tornato in difesa perché io mi
dissocio
il telo del bus bisogna indicato quando
ha pochissimo non si aspettava tutti
bene non ci arriva
nella bassa lui
grazie grazie del cross prego prego
mancato non l'hai demolito penso che lì
partono fortissimo questi la tolgo non
ho tolto niente per caso però sono
dritto in porta così una buona buona 40
è così dice forfait metto pure vicino
preso il posto di facilissimo un
angolino
si vabbè ragazzi signora quando le
regole non lo stanno abbandonando nave
dai giochiamo di toccarmi infastidisca
che voi aiuto per prima e mai partire
operato niente mentiroso lo sento io
l'ho voluta cha sono arrivato rosi ma
basta abbandonate quanto tempo come non
lo farà mai perché io contempo lo facevo
eppure io a si noti come sono stupito di
come mi ci scherzava momento del portale
si va poi a me capita invece che lo
facciamo proprio a posto la errani che
la rimonta passione 1 v1 questo sì ok
wilde e mezzo che gol non abbia visto
della montagna già vi direi che possiamo
chiudere questa partita così
tutti in action plan chiara la scena
l'unità anno madonna che no no dai
lo sfondo e sembrava e quando facciamo
così mi sembra tipo tra il novero lo
capisci a me se l'invincibile coppia
bene va bene va bene va bene va bene va
benissimo grande sin madonna incredibile
no vabbè dai michiara ga pazzesco
fighters trasmessi funzione questa qua
stiamo combattendo ci ha permesso in
comb azione vado se vuoi per chi vuole
prendere il bus tra le sale sale sale
sale sale e allora niente e chi lo
prendo questo boost aveva il controllo
siamo un piccolo pixie parte lo chiamo
l'altro per la vostra centro in modo da
avere un permesso mataj rimasta lì ferma
attenzione arriva il segmento gesù e
tranquillo
ok provando a in mezzo se riesco
lui ecco l'annuncio bus stop e tiro
radente certo no perché aiutato ad
imporla bastardo non c'è la palla io
l'avevo vampata questo qua perché
pensavo di razzi erano in porto al bus
mi sono preso tutto il karma per averlo
vantaggio senza motivo vediamo se per
caso e pericolosa
ciao ecco la loro doppio braille ritira
no ero troppo lontano e si stanno gioco
lo faccio niente dimissioni
ok mi sono finto prove faccio una roba
che non sono e che cosa sto facendo
no no no no no madonna madonna poi ti
prego mi ci ho provato di rientro sono
io ma mi tiro ma dentro vai questa balla
peccato dai ti prego insomma di tutto e
due è open non puoi sbagliare ma che di
cazzo è stata divertente almeno con
un'attenzione in aria
aiuto io tranquillo va bene non è fuori
non posso avanti così con tina maze è
veramente distante la conquista vesti
perché più bassa quindi da questa
illusione e non è visto dalla ferrari e
da preti sembra una cosa così piccola e
delicata cielo pentirò se la bomba
massaggio raccontata la passata la
passata onesto è una dai partiti bene
alla grande partita benissimo funzionava
a un vero lavoro portavamo rotto la
motta beh su questo gol
niente male o poco bus ma io sto vicino
chi non lo sa e botero dietro tutta tua
[Risate]
nell'inter che voler tirare fortissimo
protettore vado piano pro per aver
recuperato quindi ho detto cosa ho fatto
una cazzata nome di società ottima
salute senza skerzi bene anche direi
diretto perché da me piacerà l'intera
nazione per il mini page esatto avevano
quasi fra ho rischiato tantissimo di
sbagliarle con il bari madonna come the
last a voleva lo sapevi tu lo sapevi
anche tra l'altro insidiosa brazzi
c'erano proprio porco demonio quindi
ragazzi l'episodio di ogni rock di oggi
finisce qua spero che gli sia piaciuto
come detto è un bel mi piace anche per i
social coordinata descrizione bella
ragazza
[Musica]